Bienvenidos a la entrevista con Franz 24
estamos hoy con saviano Abreu portavoz
de la oficina de asuntos humanitarias de
Naciones Unidas Muchas gracias aviano
por estar hoy con nosotros gracias por
invitarme
no puedes comentar Cómo ha evolucionado
la situación humanitaria en Ucrania en
este año estamos llegando ahora bueno
llegamos Ya un año de la guerra y la
situación se ha deteriorado mucho y el
último año teníamos en enero de 2022 más
o menos 3 millones de personas aquí en
Ucrania que necesitaban ayuda
humanitaria y ahora Estamos hablando de
18 millones de personas que necesiten
ese tipo de apoyo se trata de cifras muy
llamativas Cuáles son las situaciones
más dramáticas en este momento las
situaciones más dramáticas son aquellas
personas que están más cerca del frente
tenemos más o menos un tercio de esa
población de los 18 millones que
comentaba que está poblaciones en
ciudades que están muy cerca del frente
de batalla esta gente está viviendo una
situación bastante dramática y personas
que están ya a un año Por ejemplo sin
tener agua en sus casas con que todo eso
lo conlleva no no tienen el sistema de
calefacción en las casas no tienen gas
no pueden ir a un mercado comprar una
comida de una manera natural normal que
haríamos tú y yo porque toda la cadena
de suministro se ha visto destrozada
Entonces esta es la gente que nos
preocupa más de las que estamos
intentando llegar
Ustedes han estado enviando con voice
nos puedes contar un poco cuántos han
logrado enviar A qué lugares han podido
llegar en estas en estos últimos meses
nosotros estuvimos en todas las partes
de Ucrania antes de empezar esta fase de
la guerra la guerra empezó bastante
antes no en 2014 Pero antes del 24 de
febrero Ya teníamos una respuesta
humanitaria aquí en el este del país en
las regiones de Luján indonesis pero
después del 24 de febrero tuvimos que
expandir para llegar a todas las 24
regiones las 24 provincias de aquí del
país y estamos presentes y apoyando la
población y todas estas 24 provincias
llevamos llegamos con miles y miles de
convoyes humanitarios que lleva comida
que lleva agua que lleva limpia
medicamentos a la población que la
necesita que lleva productos para
reparar las casas que han sido
bombardeadas y más o menos unos 50
convoys de estos son como es un poco más
grandes que nos unimos diferentes
agencias de Naciones Unidas ongs para ir
las poblaciones que comentaba antes que
están cerca del frente que están a 2 km
a 5 km a 10 km del frente y Ahí llegamos
de manera conjunta para llevar la ayuda
a la gente que de verdad es la que más
la necesita ahora mismo cuando envían
estos convoys informan tanto las
autoridades ucranianas como las rusas es
una parte importante del proceso estar
seguros que tanto el gobierno de Ucrania
como el gobierno de la federación Rusia
de Rusia sepan de nuestros movimientos
Ellos tienen una obligación
según el derecho internacional
humanitario debe garantizar nuestra
seguridad de facilitar nuestro acceso a
esas localidades con lo cual tenemos un
proceso de informar un sistema del
sistema de notificación humanitario que
enviamos antes de nuestros movimientos
por donde pasamos que carretera A qué
hora donde estaremos para que nuestra
seguridad esté esté garantizada que no
haya un bombardeo y una zona que estamos
prestando ayuda humanitaria
pero ustedes no tienen acceso a las
zonas ocupadas por por Rusia es correcto
uno de los desafíos desafíos que tenemos
ahora mismo es justamente llegar a la
población que está en zonas están en
zonas bajo el control de la federación
rusa nosotros tenemos operaciones ahí No
es que no estemos Te estamos presente
antes y continuamos pero la respuesta
que estar ahí que está ahí ahora es muy
limitada Porque no tenemos la capacidad
de enviar suministros desde aquí del
lado que está controlado que el gobierno
ucraniano al lado que está controlado
por Rusia desde el 24 de febrero no ha
pasado ni un camión hemos enviado
notificaciones Todas las semanas en los
últimos meses diciendo vamos a cruzar el
frente con ayuda con suministros porque
si no nuestras operaciones hay no pueden
seguir todas las veces que hacemos ese
tipo de notificaciones del gobierno de
Ucrania dice que sí que bien la
federación Rusia dice que no
y la razón o sea hay una explicación que
les dan la respuesta que nos dan cuando
nos dan una respuesta muchas veces dicen
que lo han recibido
la mayoría de las veces dicen que no nos
pueden garantizar la seguridad
pero como decía antes no es no es una
opción es una obligación y el derecho
internacional humanitario nos tiene que
facilitar el acceso Entonces nosotros
seguimos negociaciones a los más altos
niveles y también las notificaciones
para poder llegar a esta gente que está
viviendo una situación desesperada si
nosotros vamos a cerca del frente de
batalla aquí en el lado ucraniano y
vemos como como está vemos que está todo
destrozado vemos Que no hay servicios la
situación no tiene por qué ser para nada
diferente a 10 kilómetros de ahí a 5
kilómetros de ahí y esta línea que que
marca el cambio de control de las zonas
sabemos que la gente está desesperada
por ayuda queremos llegar y necesitamos
que la federación rusa facilite nuestro
acceso Cuántos corredores humanitarios
ha habido desde el pasado 24 de febrero
de 2022 solo uno es una respuesta corta
pero se ha quedado creo que todos los
medios hablaron desde el inicio de la
guerra de los corredores humanitarios de
la gente que estaba yendo de la zona
cerca del frente eso no son corredores
humanitarios los corredores humanitarios
tienen que ser acordados por los dos
lados para que haya seguridad y es una
cosa muy técnica la verdad no siempre
Necesitamos un corredor humanitario que
haya un alto el fuego por ejemplo ya
sería suficiente por ejemplo para una
evacuación el corredor humanitario se
acuerda con las dos partes un horario
determinado una ruta determinada y
pasamos la población civil pasa eso no
es lo que ha pasado aquí fueron
iniciativas de la verdad que no puedo
criticarlos porque hay muchas veces
necesarias del gobierno ucraniano de
intentar sacar a la población de ahí
pero no fue lo que decimos corredor
humanitario nosotros tuvimos uno que fue
cuando decimos la Eva civiles de las
plantas de azotestal que ahí sí hubo un
acuerdo con los dos lados se ha decidido
la ruta de la hora y por donde pasábamos
Y eso sí podemos llegar a llamar un
proceso de corredor humanitario era un
paso seguro de la población civil que
había estado atrapada y es la única vez
que lo tuvimos
esa evacuación fue una vacación que pues
recordamos un poco todos porque fue un
momento
muy importante en este conflicto
Cómo se llegó a organizarla la evocación
de los civiles de los momentos
emblemáticos de la guerra no la gente
que estaba ahí había estado cuando
pudimos llegar a ellas habían estado por
dos meses y los refugios en los bankers
de la planta siderúrgica sin condiciones
humanas para sobrevivir no veían la luz
del sol por dos meses no tenía
suficiente agua no podían ducharse la
gente que yo hable de las que vi mucha
gente no sabía duchado en dos meses eso
es muy dramático no de decirlo el
proceso de negociación fue muy largo fue
muy fue muy difícil fue muy complicado
era poder sentar dos partes dos países
en guerra y y llegar a una base mínima
para la evacuación tardó dos meses Desde
que la gente siguió atrapada ahí hasta
que pudimos llegar a ellos en mayo y
solo fue posible digo yo cuando el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez fue a Moscú hablo con
Putin vino aquí Aquí hablo con selenski
Y ahí sí pudimos tener ese ese Avance en
las negociaciones que estaban bloqueadas
y pudimos llegar a la gente que estaba
ahí
16 millones de personas son las personas
que ustedes están atendiendo en estos
momentos son las que podemos atender en
el 2022 la respuesta sigue la guerra
sigue con lo cual la necesidad de ayuda
humanitaria sigue y para este año
estamos haciendo un enfoque más al este
del país más cerca del frente y
esperamos tenemos como como objetivo
llegar a más o menos 11 millones de
personas con ayuda humanitaria desde las
Naciones Unidas y y las ongs que
trabajamos juntos Es un complemento
también al trabajo que está haciendo
miles de miles de grupos de voluntarios
por ejemplo que están aquí en el país el
gobierno ucraniano que también está
haciendo su parte entonces trabajamos
todos juntos de la mano para
complementar el trabajo uno de nosotros
y Nuestro objetivo este año es llegar a
estos 11 millones que son las personas
más vulnerables son las que más lo
necesitan y esto es nuestro foco
Quiénes son las personas que en este
momento necesitan más atención
pertenecen a colectivos específicos no
tengo ninguna duda que la gente que más
necesita nuestro apoyadora es la gente
que está cerca del frente estamos
hablando de maduración más población
mucho más vulnerable es gente que ha
decidido quedarse en zonas que están
bajo constante bombardeo son personas
mayores muchas de ellas que no pudieran
dejar sus casas o muchas veces no
quisieron o sea yo hablé con gente en
estas en estas zonas que me decían Ese
es mi casa es donde nací donde donde
crecí donde me he casado o sea no quiero
salir de aquí y esta gente está ahí Y
necesita nuestro apoyo pero no son solo
las personas mayores hay muchas de esas
poblaciones que hay niños y niñas que
están ahí porque los padres si tuvieron
que quedar porque están con las personas
mayores que les tienen que cuidar y los
niños y niñas también están personas con
problemas de locomoción que se han
quedado o personas que no tenían
recursos financieros para salir a hacer
una vida nueva en otras partes de
Ucrania puede ser muy caro sobre todo si
vas al oeste del país y ya no te digo si
tienes que vivir a un país europeo y
empezar de cero entonces esa gente que
está ahí es la gente más vulnerable que
más está sufriendo es gente que pasa
horas y horas en refugios antiaéreos es
gente que no tiene lo más básico para la
supervivencia de un ser humano y esta
gente es la que quiere es la que
queremos llegar ahora empezaste diciendo
que
desgraciadamente esta guerra no acabará
pronto ustedes están preparando para
esto para una guerra que un dure por
bastante tiempo si desgraciadamente no
vemos ahora mismo las bases mínimas por
un acuerdo de paz por supuesto desde las
Naciones Unidas vamos a seguir
trabajando para que eso pase a
inmediaciones y vamos a intentar hacerlo
pero nosotros tenemos que estar
preparados para seguir apoyando a la
población mientras la guerra siga el
futuro de este país
Está marcado por dificultades y el
futuro del mundo también no la guerra
ucraniana la guerra no digo una guerra
craneal la guerra en contra de Ucrania
diría yo tiene implicaciones globales
muy grandes y muy profundas el año
pasado los precios de alimentos subieron
una manera terrible en los primeros
meses de la guerra después de la de que
los puertos estuvieras fueran cerrados
no se podían explotar los granos
ucranianos que que alimentan a muchos
países del mundo Entonces vimos que el
hambre mundial aumentó en países que ya
estaban sufriendo con eso a causa de la
guerra Entonces el sufrimiento es aquí
es principalmente aquí pero no es solo
aquí entonces globales son son brutales
también por eso están importante que el
mundo siga no este movimiento de
solidaridad con Ucrania para ayudar a la
gente de aquí pero también para para
hacer frente a los impactos globales de
esta guerra
Muchísimas gracias por esta entrevista a
Sabino y buena suerte
[Música]